if you just arrived don't worry you
haven't missed anything important we're
just getting started
and the big big word that we're going to
discuss is scalability
so people have been talking about
scalability quite a lot in the last few
years so everyone says cloud but
generally they
mean horizontal scalability so just
let's throw more machines at whatever
problem we're trying to solve no matter
what the networking costs are what the
bandwidth will be and like how slow the
communication of the network can be
itself
so today i'm not going to touch this so
distributed computing is one of the few
things that will bypass and we'll cover
a lot of other stuff
so when we start implementing whatever
idea we have in python we generally have
a baseline
implementation that is not probably that
fast but it gets the work done
so i've marked it with a snail
us at least a nuno we
often want to go forward with faster
implementations once we have the
baseline defined
so the very first thing that you can do
is reimplement that same thing in c or c
plus in a compiled language and get
let's say a 40x performance improvement
over your baseline even in a single
threaded application sometimes which is
remarkable
another big form of acceleration is uh
or let's say vertical scaling is
enabling application specific
accelerators or let's say
purpose-specific accelerators like gpus
that we so often have in our modern
servers
but those things you may have heard
before so there is
an ambition to process data faster in
the case of the cpu or native code this
would also imply lower latency in case
of gpu processing we generally imply
higher bandwidth the latency may not
always be that good but then there is
another uh set of challenges so
essentially the baseline is python
one form of advancing your original
baseline implementation is designing
let's say a parallel native solution
which is the second row making it work
faster whatever it means and the third
row is making it bigger so like how can
you make it work with data sets that do
not fit into random access memory that's
another very challenging thing and
hopefully there is a holy grail at the
very end once those two worlds meet
working with data sets that do not fit
into random access memory and doing it
real fast so today as the first talk of
the conference i really want to give you
hope that this last step is possible and
our ecosystem is maturing for you to
have all those cool data science tools
without actually having to rewrite much
of your python code
and
frankly if there's like a 500x
difference between your baseline
implementation
and whatever you can get by changing
just a single line in your source code
why not use it so when you buy a
hardware or like a gaming rig for
yourself you would spend thousands of
dollars on a machine but if you are
using or running a code that is 500
times slower than whatever it could have
been with just a single line change in
your source code then you're essentially
boiling yourself down to raspberry pi
pico four dollar board while at the same
time you could have get you could have
gotten 16 core state-of-the-art amd cpus
and not just one but four of them
so modern hardware deserves proper
software and we're going to give it uh
to it so
just to get familiar modern server would
look like this it's a six unit six and a
half unit rack mountable server it will
have tons of state-of-the-art ssds it
will have 64-core cpus in it and a ton
of networking
but
even when we start programming those
machines we would often times start with
libraries like numpy pandas and network
x
raise your hands if numpy sounds
familiar
if
panda sounds familiar
and network x have you ever used it
okay far less and it's the general trend
so as the data and the data form becomes
less regular
uh it becomes more challenging to work
with it and we'll also see in the
following implementations so i have only
briefly referencing some of the
libraries that you can replace your
original choice with to get a faster
implementation and many of those
libraries would have a prefix coup which
stands for cuda implying gpu
acceleration and i'm pretty sure in the
next two days you'll have a lot of guys
explaining how this works under the hood
aside from those there are other
attempts to implement native
acceleration so moden would be an
analogous project trying to give you
a native implementations of data frames
uh and it's pushed forward uh
not explicitly by another big hardware
vendor let's not call the names
but then there are some completely open
source projects
so redworkx
has an arc in the beginning who knows in
which language network x is implemented
see not too many options c i give it
away with r
yes okay we have a winner winner here
stefan
so i've also referenced some of the
libraries that will give you horizontal
scalability like das qdf but i told you
we're not going to talk about
distributed computing or computing over
the network today so what it could be
well distributed can mean a lot of
things such as having
multiple machines working together on
multiple chips working together so das
qdf would allow you to also scale beyond
one single gpu with data sets that do
not fit into vram of a single chip
but okay
this conference is about python and data
processing not c or cudent data
processing oh i'm here to tell you that
you will not have to write a single line
of c to get this working so it's just
python to give it a slightly more
structured form
uh
let's classify them into tabular
implementations native versus gpu
acceleration
and one interesting thing to note is i
have question marks here
and
numpy is surprisingly in two categories
so
we'll remember that question mark
and now we'll concentrate on the
question how hard the transition can be
for your sources in your application to
become let's say 20 30 times faster
so
numpy
is a lie
and it's just a face
in reality there's a lot of interesting
stuff happening under the hood so it
gives you a very convenient form of
working with matrices and higher rank
tensors but in reality there's like this
standard defined i think in 1919 1979
or something like that which is called
blas basically in algebra subreddins it
is
one of those standards that definitely
aged well it has three layers of
operations vector vector operations
vector matrix and matrix matrix
operations and often times or probably
always
it's implemented in c c plus plus or
just native assembly raw assembly but
originally it was implemented in fortran
so when i say it's a standard one of the
cool things for you to immediately grasp
is that it do not really force a
specific implementation so you can have
the same usable front as the numpy gives
to you and under the hood there will be
a hardware accelerated implementation
that is completely detached from your
original nine pi solution and whenever
you use pip install
or conde install it's just a man a
question of adding a couple of
specifications in a square brackets
right after your install declarations
for for you to instruct the underlying
package manager which specific
distribution of numpy you want installed
so
uh
one of those
to remember and generally the one that i
would recommend for you to start right
away with is intel mkl so mkl
surprisingly has no b l a or s
in the abbreviation
which is very uncommon for blast
libraries almost all of them have at
least one of those four letters but mkl
stands for math kernels library it's a
very big package that includes a blast
distribution optimized for x86 cpus and
note here i'm saying x86 implying that
it will work fine not just on intel
hardware but also amd cpus
and last but not the least there is
coupe i and whenever we want to talk
about performance it makes sense to
describe what kind of benchmark we have
so uh
we love doing benchmarks uh generally
they are pretty thorough but like to be
honest for this conference and talk we
wanted just to give you a basic
understanding with some of the most
common operations so some of them would
be more like linear algebra operations
like the one on the left uh in the
middle on the slide so like matrix
multiplications svds phosphorus
transforms
another ones would not even have native
implementation and numpy such as like
moving averages computation which is at
the very top
and the others will be like purely
arithmetical and will include things
such as reductions median calculations
and when i say arithmetical i implied
that do not really take into account any
of the structure uh that you provide
with the input so like it doesn't matter
if it's a matrix a rank three times or
whatever for those functions just like a
continuous array and you need to analyze
all the numbers uh regardless of their
position
so the cool thing here is as if we have
an interface
and the underlying implementation can be
obstructed away you can have a lot of
very custom exotic hardware
actually implementing the number
quenching and i say exotic i mean it
like this is the kind of chips that uh
even given all my pure love for hardware
i haven't worked myself with but being
in the industry for a few years i have
an expectation that once i get those
chips and i have the blast distribution
that comes with it i will be able to
rebuild numpy and link it together with
a provided blast implementation and my
python source code will work right out
of the box on those chips and to give
you an understanding of how different
those chips are from what we generally
run on let's start with graph core top
right corner so it's like
a uk-based hardware startup that designs
semi-neuromorphic chips so
the architecture would imply putting
more memory next to every single core
uh and uh memory is like a vague
description like it can it can mean
persistent memory like ssd it can mean
ram vram
it can mean sram i'm talking about sram
specifically
so if you take an a100 gpu it will have
40 or 80 gigabytes of vram uh
if i'm not mistaken hbm2
uh and it will also have
just 40 gigabytes of sram oh sorry 40
megabytes of sram so like three out of
three orders of magnitude less memory
on the graph core chips you will have
900 megabytes of sram memory available
to all the like
a chunk of it is available to each core
and that's given that the number of
transistors and the size of the chip is
roughly the same as the a100 but then
there are like the colossal chips of the
future i would say so like cerebros a uk
a us-based startup they design
what they call wave for scale computing
so they take the whole wafer and instead
of cutting it into smaller chips
they pack it into a single server that
is as huge as half of the rack so it's
considerably taller than the djx a100
which comes with eight gpus but this
thing only has one chip and this chip
boosts uh
2.6 trillion transistors compared to 60
trillion or 60 billion in chips like the
a100
so with cupid
the transition would be as simple as
just changing the import so import coupe
i as np at the very top and who can spot
the only one other difference between
this slide and this light
uh you don't have to really to spot it
to be honest
so pearson correlation statement
uh again the input statement is
different oh the import yes but aside
from that the function definition for
person correlation benchmark
has uh three arguments in this
implementation and just two arguments
over here and those are the kind of
tiny tricky little differences that will
exist between different implementations
of the packages or may exist between
different
uh implementations of the packages so
with coupe i and numpy
in both of those cases there's like no
universal rule as if every function has
a d type argument or if it doesn't so
oftentimes when you do not provide this
kind of argument that will take all the
inputs and we'll use the biggest color
type that you provided as
the scholar type of the output
those kinds of differences you have to
account for whenever you port your
library oh sorry import your application
from one backend to another
another notable thing if by any chance
you're doing any high performance stuff
or high resolution stuff there are
differences in the way you cast integers
or floats between different backends and
for those of us who have maybe like more
computer science background that will be
pro proper uh like entirely
understandable so even though there's
like this single ieee 754 standard for
floating point operations
and even if your arithmeticological
units on the gpu and on the cpu
implemented identically following the
standard
whenever you have let's say a
heterogeneous program part of which will
work on the cpu and part will be
compiled for the gpu they may not be
compiled with exactly the same options
so you may have fast math flags enabled
for the gpu code and all of a sudden the
math will become inaccurate and will not
match whatever you had on the cpu
predictions
another notable thing is that uh
oftentimes gpu drivers like live with
their own timeline they have their own
queue of operations and uh this is true
for cuba it's also true for dusk even
though it may not necessarily
be about gpu back-ends of dusk but those
asynchronous frameworks they may
sometimes require you to put additional
synchronization points in your source
code just making sure that whatever the
work scheduled for the gpu execution up
until this point
uh has finished before you can proceed
or let's say send the data back to the
cpu to do like the final post processing
and
very importantly
universal functions are not always
universal another big lie
so universal function that functions are
the freestanding functions so
essentially the ones defined globally at
in numpy not as member functions
on matrices or tensors so in numpy it's
very convenient that you can provide
native python types such as lists as
arguments to the universal functions it
may not necessarily be a numpy array
that you pass in
with high performance packages
unfortunately you may not have those
freedoms so a high performance
implementation would
imply that you're working with very
fixed
readable
and somewhat rigid from python's
perspective implementations of buffers
and the race and this is an important
thing to remember and we'll come back to
it but before it
the big promise why are we doing all of
it
and uh the answer is speed sometimes uh
the
the boost that we are getting are not
really
the ones that we expect so just to
clarify every row here is a kind of
operation that we had defined on
previous slides every column is a
different size of the input meaning
different sizes of matrices the first
column being a matrix with 512 by 512
floating point numbers as the most
common content of your matrices and the
last column uh describes benchmarks for
matrices that have 17 000 rows and 17
000 colors
columns respectively
and
uh i've color coded some of the results
in worst case scenario your soft your
source may become slower
yes it happens
but very rarely and
like you have to cherry pick to find
those cases when q pi will actually like
do real bad but sometimes you would get
performance improvements at a factor of
uh 1000 and i'm not even saying like
compared to a baseline numpy
implementation we took the fastest numpy
implementation which is the mkl
we took the fastest cpu on the planet
we've liquid cooled it we've overclocked
it and we took the fastest uh
available gaming gpu which is not the
fastest server gpu and we've also
overclocked it and uh took them head to
head
sometimes when it comes to mathematical
operations if you have mixed precision
enabled you may not even get just boosts
in matrix uh multiplications from the
tensor cores available on the last three
generations of nvidia gpus but you may
also get the performance boosts in
non-matrix multiplication operations uh
just thanks to a couple of cool
optimizations under the hood
so if we
if it was just about the libraries or
specific separate libraries there would
be very little to celebrate here it
would involve a lot of additional work
for you just to go and find every
separate solution mix them together but
luckily hardware vendors are uniting to
help us
and uh i'm not really uh describing this
ecosystem in full so there's cupid qdf
and kilgraf which oftentimes have exact
one-to-one mappings to libraries that
are familiar to you sometimes they come
with packages or let's say functions
inside that you never expect in the
original implementation and my favorite
example
as a machine learning practitioner and
natural language processing practitioner
is that qdf internally has functions for
text tokenization so
for every library with the q prefix
there is a library with envy prefix so
essentially one of them would be let's
say python level developer the ones that
are with q and nv standing for nvidia is
the underlying c library that makes all
the all of the magic possible so there
is a library called envy text that comes
with three gpu and like hardware
accelerated tokenizers that you can use
for your natural language processing
pipelines which oftentimes includes
models like bird and for byte pairing
coatings for hashing tokenizers you will
have functions embedded into qd apps
underlying envy text package that you
can call on your columns of strings cool
thing to remember but then there are
also a few packages that i haven't
mentioned here
one of them is q spatial if you're doing
any spatial reasoning
another one is clx so whenever you work
with data frames
there are also additional functions to
convert
string representations into some forms
of scholars or let's say logical types
specific for your application
we have date times like this and pandas
but for some other applications you may
want to parse things such as ip
addresses and an ip address represented
as a string
in worst case scenario is three by four
which is 12 plus three which is 15 15
characters and we just encode it as a
string
so an ip4 ipv4 address is just a 32-bit
integer why not just like work with it
uh so for all of that and for cyber
security applications for kids who
analyze a lot of different logs and i
know there's plenty of cyber security
startups in armenia you could use clx to
parse your pandas data frames of logs
and prepare the data for machine
learning pipeline and for detection and
for fraud detection much faster
another thing that
is pretty popular on github but somehow
i almost never see people using it is
qml which implements some of the more
classical machine learning
tools
uh such as clustering algorithms like
umap and tsne tsne and umap are some of
the most famous visualization tools and
dimension reduction tools
aside from those uh there's also things
such as arima uh ultra aggressive uh
what's the ic for i guess integrated
moving averages
uh or something along those lines so
it's very relevant for time series
analysis
and then there is a qx filter so for the
final end of your pipeline when you want
to visualize your stuff it's not
necessarily that you have to get your
matplotlib your plotly
or dash you can use qrex filter to build
up more performance dashboards with
whatever is supplied by the rest of the
ecosystem
and who notices uh
rock m on the slide who knows what that
stands for
there's a guy there do you know what
that stands for
great answer
i'm a bit too mouthful with every one of
my descriptions this is much shorter and
more concise so there is rock amp or hip
those like two abbreviations that you
have to remember and whenever you see
those uh things are going about amd gpus
so as every vendor is getting their
discrete gpus into the data center and
as this year we had our first exascale
computer being officially unveiled and
benchmarked for the top 500 of
supercomputers the frontier in the
oakridge national lab this system is
famously packed with like 10 000 servers
with four gpus in each one of them which
makes up for 40 000 gpus and all of them
are amd how the hell are you going to
program them it's a bit complicated
especially if you're not doing some
custom weather simulation software that
you implement for one platform
specifically but with some of the rock
and hip ports and with a bit of
additional work on the llvm compiler
we'll be able to get a lot of this
python code and gpu acceleration to the
amd and intel hardware quite soon
so as you see uh
results are becoming less and less
uniform in a sense that many packages
may not have the implementation for the
algorithm that we're interested in for
let's say graph processing so as the
data again becomes less regular the less
packages and less consistency between
the implementations still you may get
the thousand times performance
improvements if you know what you're
doing but notably snap and igraph do not
provide the same interface as network x
so here a more fair comparison would
have been redworks and cool graph as the
interface is identical
another important things i get
i guess even more important than network
processing for most of you guys is
working with really big tabular data
sets
and we do nom have a really fast
database backend that we implement for
our internal data management and a good
benchmark for this kind of thing would
be
the new york taxi rides data set so it's
uh there is a very famous blog on
internet comparing all the sql databases
in terms of their speed of processing
this data set it's two billion rides
from uh new york shared from by new york
authorities uh by different taxiry
hailing platforms
and uh
it implements just four queries
generally those are implemented in sql
in different dialects of databases we
implemented them with the pandas
interface and uh just to make
the benchmark
uh repeatable on commodity hardware not
our servers and clusters and in adequate
amount of time instead of taking the few
hundreds of gigabytes worth of data that
make up those two billion rows we took
small samples of it and we put them put
moden which is like native backend and
qdf head to head and unfortunately for
modding at least today the benchmarks
were not very good so for us it didn't
make much sense to use let's say modern
on the cpu backend and i guess uh it's
fair to say that pandas interface is
very complicated it has too many
functions and whenever you're
implementing a new library a new backend
for the same with the same interface
it's very tough to get everything right
from the very beginning and sometimes
when you miss up a function
uh this function will be then redirected
to the original pandas implementation so
if you're calling something in in modern
that is not implemented your are beneath
triggering the
pandas implementation not always
knowingly
so
when working with tables and with
different sorting group by operations on
the gpu side we consistently would get
let's say 10 to 50x performance
improvements
the bad side here again gpu memory is
very is very limited though luckily for
you if you are not really targeting for
the top quantile of performance and your
computer is not that let's say a billion
dollar supercomputer
you can get away by uh using what is
let's say today's our next-gen
technology so there's a lot of effort to
bring unified memory into the ecosystem
so that all of your chips would have the
same address space for the data they
store and the driver beef will do the
smart work of let's say fetching and
moving the data around so that if your
data fits at least into ram it will be
pulled in parts onto the gpu whenever
it's needed there so that's one easy yet
not the most performant way for you to
scale to big data sets on the gpu and
just uh for the sake of completeness
there are a few other names i have to
throw around for you to go and do your
research at home
and you can write that write them down
my favorite out of those is probably
number
definitely your swiss army knife for
let's say
easy optimizations and acceleration of
your software
and uh importantly i want to talk about
like say a few big problems with python
and how the ecosystem is partnering
together to solve them so python's most
common sequential type is a list
and even if we do not look into the
underlying implementation in the c
python runtime uh any person familiar
with let's say linked list
implementation would know that it's not
really the most efficient form for
enumeration let alone the fact so
there's no locality and you have to jump
around
it's even worse when you understand that
you're working with integers and the
integers are packed into some
variable length representation so python
out of all the languages that i've used
i guess is the only one that doesn't
have fixed length integer representation
another big problem as i mentioned not
using the ability to convert to enum
types so moving from strings to
categories and then parsing date times
as integers before starting to use them
and uh
another thing to note again
so if we had those lists and lists are
horrible why not we make the next step
and make
continuous memory layouts
so there was a lot of effort to go there
and
when choosing your algorithm in the
future make sure you understand your
data layout so is it sparse is it dance
is it a matrix or a let's say adjacency
list but people had tried to solve all
of it
so
we'll talk very little about developing
software and we'll focus on developing
intuition so but developing software
it's important to note that there is
this pep standard python enhancement
proposal 3118 which defines a sea struck
that we developers can use to exchange
information about tensors of various
rank between uh
number crunching packages
you have to just implement this to be
able to provide tensors from one runtime
to another and the same for columnar
representations so apache arrow is the
new big family of standards that uh
pulled inside the pocket uh set of
formats
feather has now become a apache arrow
ipc2 standard
and this is a new form of data frames
essentially
so just to note this would allow you to
send data from one place to another
without needing to convert it every time
you switch a package
so developing the intuition i would
recommend you to use maybe native python
types of very tiny sequences
anything bigger would probably boil down
to numpy
multi-threaded and hardware accelerated
cpu libraries are only meaningful if
you're working with elements that are
let's say tens of thousands
and you whenever you want you can pack
your native implementation with pipebind
nanobind boost or boost python or swig
and then another thing
is the gpu libraries so all of that
recovered but is there more
so we work with 10 with data says there
are tens of terabytes so let's say i
want to work with data sets that are
hundreds of terabytes on every single
machine
how
let's taste
the future
and see what's about to come to the
ecosystem
of python data science libraries
so
you have all those pieces in your modern
computer like a cpu ssd nic gpu and ram
all of them used to talk to each other
through the cpu exchanging the data
through
one link and this link is wide but not
wide enough to accommodate for modern
data transmission rates
luckily aside from let's say apache aero
or that pep standard there is more
happening in the ecosystem
lower in the hardware level so or let's
say the driver level so at the driver
level there is a standard bind video for
the gpu direct storage for sending the
data from gpu uh sorry from ssd onto the
gpu bypassing the cpu entirely
for bridging the device of the chips
within the same server together in the
same address space there are a lot of
unified addressing technologies and
efforts implemented
for being able to share ram
has one continuous block or let's say
continuously addressable block between
not one machine but many machines there
is remote direct memory access which
will you
more often see as rdma so it may sound
familiar and then there is also a nvme
of a fabric we want to use all those
technologies to bring two very
complicated worlds together the world of
working with very big data sets that are
hundreds of terabytes
and gpu acceleration where the memory
bandwidth of vram is let's say 1.5
terabytes per second on every chip
so
by doing all of it imagine having common
crawl which is the biggest publicly
available data set on the planet right
now the one that is famously used to
train some of the biggest generative uh
and
not just generative language models
uh but generally it's not even used
entirely people use different samples of
it we want to be able to process this
entire data set on just two machines in
a matter of 20 minutes without any
additional indexing
so
for those of you who will want to go
down the road of understanding all all
of this complexity of designing
something like this not just using
there's a lot of there are a lot of
problems in designing a parallel
algorithm i famously used to ask
kids on interviews uh who never
programmed on gpus on how to implement a
parallel reduction
when you have 10 000 cores under your
disposal but the same kind or like very
different but still challenging things
are external memory algorithms how do
you sort the data when you cannot just
jump around and swap things together
like with quicksort
as with any kind of a benchmark like
this uh or any kind of challenge there
is uh
a consortium of people on the internet
who love weird stuff and there is a
benchmark even for external memory
memory algorithms that you can go and
look into
and you would immediately see that even
the algorithms are implemented there are
very different from the algorithms that
you're starting in your cs class
so the hope is what we develop so we
have a hybrid transaction analytical
processing tool that hopefully will do
both the low latency operations like the
right transactions and the read
intensive operations as the analytics
for you
and will bridge together with the rest
of the ecosystem so as there was this
blas with a linear algebra standard that
was designed like 40 years ago we want
to design similar standard for create
read update and delete operations on
your data processing pipeline with just
a very narrow c layer in between and a
lot of libraries growing out of it for
the high level interfaces and a lot of
different logic implemented beneath for
you to be able to use with the it's
entirely open source you can check it on
github and the cool thing is in the
bottom left corner here unmdb persistent
asset store it's the first uh engine
database engine
uh with gpu acceleration support ever
designed and by far the fastest out of
those who have cpu acceleration with
send instructions on three generations
of x86 cpus
and on arm cpus as well
so with all of it you can
look into it online i've mentioned a few
potential usages for this kind of system
especially if you have let's say
data transmission intensive application
like a recommender system that would
often have a different trade-off between
i o and the number of the amount of
compute
will also be very uh we are very excited
to learn about your use cases so we can
adjust for them and prepare data loaders
and stuff like that for python
tensorflow
so that's it
check out ukv
check out unum and feel free to ask me
any questions you have okay thank you
now it's time for questions
yes
thank you for your presentation it was
quite interesting
like uh the processes right now are
deterministic there are not
probabilistic so they only give zeros
and ones and uh uh we are calculating
like parabolistic answers
we uh like in a core it doesn't matter
if the answer is like 99.99
or
99.998
so i know there are
new types of processors
that don't divide between zeros and ones
so in a core i don't remember quite the
name of them i was trying to google but
in uh
atomic level they don't the wall between
zero and one isn't divided like strictly
so the electrons can flow between the
zero and one and it gives a
probabilistic answer like a
probabilistic value so these kind of
chips
are now are being developed and are
being used to calculate some uh machine
learning tasks in on a probabilistic
level
i can't remember the name of those chips
uh have you heard about this and what is
your answer what is your comment on this
um so i do not know which one
specifically you want to reference but
there is this amazing branch of
analogous computing so as there's binary
logic and like all the
algorithms that we design for it there's
also analogous computing which yes has
a very probabilistic nature to it and
that you are not really defining your
program you define your program but uh
it's more of a form of simulation and
you let the computer uh naturally unfold
the simulation to give you the answer so
it's a very different programming model
and the results would also be very
different so are there libraries being
developed on these things or in this
case there are a couple of uh answers
here so
there are a lot of algorithms
designed for digital computers to
simulate the expected behavior of an
analogous system so an example would be
frameworks for simulations of quantum
computation
but quantum computing is not the only
form so like there's a lot of effort
happening in optical computing space
and
that's not the only one either
hopefully that answers the question
yeah thanks thanks for the
great presentation
actually the question is related to the
crops and plus
i saw that
you have
such rigorous benchmarks related to the
cuda et cetera i wonder if you have
if you have done such fork related to
the craft plus
if you have any size benchmark related
to it and if you can share that i'll be
very grateful thanks
uh yes sure great question thank you
very much didn't expect that one so for
context graph plus
is a different kind of
package so it also implements the blast
operations
but they are parameterized over the ring
on which the arithmetics are carried so
instead of just like doing let's say the
dot product matrix multiplication
you would uh use something like a
tropical semi ring uh with let's say
minimum and maximum operations and then
all of a sudden the matrix product of
two adjacency matrices uh sorry
matrix product
of an adjacency matrix of a graph with
itself will give you the implementation
of the floyd version algorithm for all
shortest path problem on graphs very
cool bridge between let's say an
implementation and the above logic for
the discrete structure
in terms of uh possible implementations
there is a library called cutlass which
is a c plus plus template library for q2
gpus uh
it's templated so i'm pretty sure it can
be parameterized but internally at uno
we have our own graph plus
implementation with both cpu and gpu
backhands and
i'm not 100 sure as of now we're
definitely slow in cpu so we're
significantly slower than mkl but we
might be the fastest on the gpu right
now and the difference if you like the
difference between the gpu and the cpu
implementation would be absolutely
staggering like if you have a gpu go use
it
you